I came here for the first time when I
was 14 years old I never really thought
about architecture before but this was
the first time I thought wow this is a
really nice building and this space kind
of made me feel something this was the
first time I started to think about the
people who created this building the
more and more I visited buildings I
started to notice the different ways it
made me feel and so for me architecture
was always kind of synonymous to
something that you can go inside and
experience and feel and something that
was built but then I went to
architecture school and I saw a project
like this and this and this and I also
designed projects like this and this so
why do Architects design projects that
are not meant to be built a portion of
this video is sponsored by paperlike
more on them later in this video before
I can explain that I need to explain
what is architecture well first and
foremost architecture is a tool it's a
tool for us to influence how people use
space and how people interact with the
space and with each other using space
and form
[Music]
this has a different relationship to
this and this has a different
relationship to this and because it
reflects our Behavior changes in
architecture is usually a pretty good
reflection of the changes in our social
or cultural or economic values this is
your typical shingle style house from
the early 20th century with a typical
cross-shaped plan a central steer core a
typical arrangement of the public rooms
on the first floor and a wrap around
veranda and this is a very similar plan
designed by Frank Lloyd Wright can you
see the difference this was during a
time when the Dynamics at home were
really changing and a lot of people
wanted a better connection between these
rooms
and so a lot of Architects they try to
achieve by increasing the opening in
these walls
but what Frank Lloyd Wright did is he
overlapped the geometry is to create one
continuous floor Hughes intermediate
elements like fireplaces or screens to
divide the space but you can still see
the continuity of the floor and the
ceiling so it makes it feel like one big
open space and then later he started to
offset the geometry from the grid to
give even a better connection between
the spaces his houses started to take
the form of whatever the function was
happening on the inside and he started
to take a lot more liberties with the
geometry and the Symmetry then there was
the open plan
instead of a building being a series of
boxes and closets
became more and more open more and more
a sense of space
the outside came in more and more and
the inside went out more
that went along until we had a
practically a new floor plan Frank Lloyd
Wright built over 500 homes over the
time span of six decades so when you
look at the evolution of his designs
throughout the years you can also see
the changes in our culture and our
economy in the 1920s the Great
Depression hit and a lot of people
didn't have the money to spend on homes
so he developed a much more economical
design which he called the usonian home
he condensed the entire house into a
single story in the shape of an L with
the communal rooms on one leg and the
private rooms on the other people didn't
have servants anymore and it was the
average housewife doing most of the work
and so the kitchen gets a lot more
Compact and it's located in a more
central location so at the housewife can
have eyes in both directions he
developed multiple iterations of this
depending on the cost and the size of
the family and he designed it in a way
by if the family grew the family could
just add another room in this direction
fast forward to today cooking becomes
more trendy and the kitchen becomes a
part of the entertainment and so for a
lot of people the kitchen is actually
where you spend a lot of your money on
these walls disappear the kitchen and
the living room become more connected
and you get a much more open space and
as we shape the function we change the
shape and also the form of the building
function space form function space form
function space form but if you ask any
architect they're going to tell you form
follows function which follows form
which which follows shape
foreign
a lot of paper
yeah but I like drawing on paper have
you tried using paper like for your iPad
no what is it I use paper like to give
my iPad that paper feeling
like what well have you tried paper like
2.1 it's got even better Clarity and
visibility because they improve the
material composition the nanodots which
are the little micro beads that I add
resistance to your stylus they're spread
more evenly across the surface that
means with this new iteration the images
are sharper and crisper than paper-like
too while having the same texture and
feeling
whoa check the link in the description
for more information
and lastly you incorporate time into the
equation because you don't just
experience Space by just looking at it
right you either walk through it or you
sit around it for an extended period of
time when we walk through a series of
arcades we experience the Rhythm the
light Bouncing Around The Arches so we
might feel our steps going down when we
go from a narrow space to an open space
we might feel a sense of expansion we
might even experience a sense of awe but
there's another aspect to architecture
which is meaning because we're complex
sophisticated creatures we always attach
meaning to things to things that might
not even have a meaning Remember When
Donald Trump said he wanted all the
federal buildings to be in the classical
style that's obviously absurd classical
style came from a very specific time and
place and so to try to force fit that
into our society it doesn't really
reflect who we are today right but it is
symbolic and it's symbolic of and I
quote the dignity Enterprise Vigor and
stability of the American system of
self-government and by using this
architecture they wanted to create an
image for the government that was in
control but this doesn't mean the same
thing now as it did back in the 18th
century and neither does this neither
does this and sometimes architecture
doesn't really remind us of anything it
just makes us feel something
foreign
[Music]
because architecture is a combination of
all of these things and because it's so
intertwined with our culture and our
behavior and how we interact with each
other it's kind of the perfect way for
us to ask questions about who we are and
how we are and where we want to be this
is one of boulay's buildings that was
never meant to be built about two
decades after Newton's death one of his
prodigies reached out to Boule you might
not know this but Newton actually died
before his ideas became popularized so a
lot of people living before the
enlightenment they had never really
heard of his ideas but when boulay
learned about them he was mesmerized he
wanted to honor him with a Worthy
cenotaph
foreign
just look at the scale of this thing
it's a 150 meter tall sphere taller than
the gray pyramids this is a scale of a
person so you can kind of get a sense of
how big this thing is it's nestled into
this pedestal and it's encircled by
hundreds of cypress trees which gives it
the illusion of being both half buried
into the Earth and hovering from gravity
in order for you to reach the inside you
need to walk into this long dark tunnel
you're walking for almost 150 meters in
the darkness your eyes adapt to the dark
you're probably feeling a little bit
scared and the more you walk you feel
yourself getting farther and farther and
farther from reality once you reach the
end you're in this Grand concrete sphere
when you enter you feel this sense of
release and you're inspired by the
magnitude of the space it's designed so
that if it's day outside light pierces
through these holes in the vaulting
which creates the illusion of stars in
the night sky when you come in at night
it's the opposite the spherical light
fixture hangs in the center of the
sphere and it creates this mysterious
glow of daylight
although this building would never get
built I think boulay created poetry
through his architecture and he really
expressed what it means to be a human in
this world we actually have a name for
these types of projects the projects
that are never meant to be built it's
called paper architecture let me know if
you have a favorite unbuilt project and
if you want to check out my paper
architecture I'll leave the playlist
right here if you like this video please
leave me a thumbs up
and if you're not subscribed subscribe
button is right there and with that I'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]